foreign
[Music]
morning good afternoon to all attendees
and thank you for joining this webinar
event my name is Stefan fat I'm a
manager in manufacturing in the
bioscience divisions of Thermo Fisher
Scientific and currently I'm heading the
protein Service Group at the China site
in ringsburg Germany and as mentioned by
the title of this presentation today I
would like to talk about strategies for
high tider protein expression using
highly Advanced expression systems with
expression optimized genes
before that I would like to start with
our with our mission at therm official
scientific which is to enable our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer and this especially
holds true in this ancient time of a
global pandemic where we support our
customers in their efforts against the
covid-19 pandemic just as an example
here at gnat we are supporting this
fight against the covid-19 disease as we
already produced several thousand genes
as well as some proteins for vaccine
development or for molecular Diagnostics
I would like to start with a quick look
at the agenda and what will be covered
during today's talk I'm going to start
out with a brief overview of g-nut
services and talk about some key
application of synthetic genes before
then I will briefly talk about Gene
synthesis and introduce you to our
multi-parameter optimization approach
and how this approach benefits protein
expression
in the second part I will show that we
have access to the highest tider systems
on the market as we are partnering with
the cell bio and with the gibco team of
thermal facial scientific as we utilize
the XP 293 and xputual protein
expression platforms and finally I will
introduce our gene2 protein service and
by doing this I will demonstrate how
your research can benefit from combining
those Advanced expression system with
expression optimized genes and how we
can support your research by offering a
complete workflow solution from Gene to
protein
so the service offering provided a gnat
covers the full workflow from Gene to
protein or if requested only parts of
this work all you need is submit or
provide a digital DNA or amino acid
sequence and several days later you will
receive a highly expressed purified and
analyzed protein to your door and in
addition to Pure Gene synthesis or
protein Services we can also provide you
with genevariants or we can build whole
complex Gene libraries providing
technology which enables options to
adapt protein properties to your
specific needs
and this comprehensive product and
service portfolio all comes from one
hand everything we do is done in-house
so there is no need of material or data
transfer which is very crucial for many
of our Pharma and biotech customers and
of course we are committed to do our
work to the highest quality standards
and we have a quite easy to order
process via web-based ordering platform
or via a very dedicated customer care
team
so key application for synthetic genes
of course are manifold they can range
from basic research to cell line
optimization synthetic genes play a role
in genetic engineering in gene therapy
but during today's talk I would like to
focus on their use for transient
expression and especially for antibody
optimization and antibody or protein
production
so usually Gene to protein Services they
start entirely from scratch as Gene
synthesis meanwhile became state of the
art since it is a very cost effective
and time and resource saving method so
here at gnat we are considered as the
excellent sender for writing DNA
offering a world-class optimization
technology significant production
capacities so just as an example we have
production capacities for over 30 000
oligos a days and we are producing more
than 11 megabase pairs or more than 11
000 genes a month a month and of course
all of those synthetic genes are
sequence verified according to newest
next Gene sequencing technology with
capacities of more than 28 000 sequence
reads a day
and again your synthetic team is only
Built based on a digital sequence which
is provided by you as the customer it
then will be cloned for example in our
PC DNA 3.4 protein expression Vector
which is optimized for best performance
and then it can be immediately used for
protein production
so if in if your interest is protein
production why should you then go with
an optimized Gene and one reason for
sure and this has been for many many
years is that of course codon usage
affects protein expression so while you
have a genetic code that is universal
you have 61 codons that code for only 20
amino acids and out of those 20 amino
acids 18 amino acids use synonymous
codons and those alternative codons
again are used with an unequal frequency
and in addition to that the codon usage
patterns differ in each and every
organism so apparently if you recall
critical steps during protein expression
the codon usage of the transgene plays a
critical role as it has to match the
TRNA availability of the host cell
but of course especially in mammalian
cells gene expression is a much more
complex process and it is influenced by
many additional factors such as for
example GC content direct repeats or RNA
secondary structures which can be huge
obstacles for the ribosomal Machinery
during that translational process
so if you take a look now at this align
sequence on the left of this slide which
should represent a wild type sequence
here you can see that this sequence
might not be optimal for protein
expression since it contains some
unfavorable codons which are highlighted
here in Red so what you could do now is
you could do a simple code on back
translation by simply replacing those
unfavorable codons in Red by the most
favorable codons for the given
expression hosts which are highlighted
here in green but such a simple code on
back translation might also not be
optimal for protein expression as you
might introduce additional unwanted
motives such as repetitions or any
secondary structures which in the end
then might hamper protein expression so
the goal always is you need to find a
trade-off between codon optimization and
those additional motives which are
influencing protein expression
and this is why our It software
Engineers developed an algorithm which
is not a simple codon optimization but
actually is an RNA optimization which
takes up to 20 parameters into account
in order to optimize MMA encoding region
so how do you solve now such a
multi-parameter optimization problem
which of course can be a huge
mathematical problem just considering a
chain which codes for a protein with a
hundred amino acids it is simply
impossible to analyze or to
yeah to analyze all possible codon
combinations and this again is why our
It software Engineers here at gnat
developed a so-called sliding window
approach and what this approach does it
actually does test all possible codon
combinations however it only does this
in a very limited window of 10 to 20
amino acids within this window the very
best codon combination is created the
very first codon is locked down and then
this window slides or moves along your
sequence from the five Prime to the
three prime end of your Gene and the
whole process is done over and over
again and by doing this your optimized
sequence is constantly growing
and obviously of course furthermore an
extended window is considered for
evaluating the best codon combination
just to ensure that at later time points
you are not introducing again any motive
such as secondary structures which might
be
they are hampering protein expression
so when it comes to the production of
human proteins of course production of
human recombinant proteins became an
indispensable process in modern
biotechnology and biomedicine
by far mammalian in and E coli horse are
the most prominent expression systems
for this purpose the advantages for
ecolo E coli are obvious it's fast
growing it's easy to handle it's very
cheap and basically and completely
understood organisms however E coli
expression also has several
disadvantages severe disadvantages such
as the lack of post-translational
modifications you don't have a suitable
membrane environment for membrane
proteins
over-expression of your protein might
lead to misfolding and aggregation which
requires then a lot of efforts to
resolubilize your protein from inclusion
bodies and of course you are very
restricted on large size and oligomeric
proteins and finally if it comes to the
production of antibodies it's simply
impossible to produce an authentic human
glycoprotein and according to this more
than 70 percent of recombinant protein
Pharmaceuticals and most proteins used
for vaccination human therapy or
Diagnostics are currently produced in
mammalian cells since
simply circumvents all those obstacles
of E coli expression
this leaves only the question why an
optimization is still required for the
production of a human protein in an
autologous host and the answer is quite
simple since nature did not optimize
genes for maximum expression but rather
for maximum regulation and so you're
still facing severe obstacles for
protein expression such as
transcriptional silencing mRNA
destabilization splicing events
premature polyadenylation events or
simply a very inefficient translational
process
so apparently all problems of gene
expression can find their Source in the
strength Gene itself and this is why we
believe that Gene optimization is one
first step to overcome any protein
expression problems
and to prove that our optimization
approach our optimization algorithm is
working we conducted a first large-scale
studying addressing the influence of
multi-parameter optimization on an
autologous in an autologous host for
human protein expression and what we did
here is we simply chose 50 standard
human genes from the ncbi data bank
which are representing the most
interesting protein classes among them
were kinases transcription factors
ribosomal protein in cytokines and
membrane proteins and then we denovo
synthesized those proteins as optimized
as well as wild type constructs and then
we transfected them those those
constructs into heck 293 cells in
triplicates and basically made a
head-to-head comparison of wild type
versus optimized expression and as you
can see here on this Slide the optimized
construct basically outperformed their
wild type counterparts in each and every
case so the result of the study was that
in 96 percent of cases the optimized
construct showed at least equal
expression as the wild type counterpart
while indeed in 86 percent of of of
proteins the the optimized construct
significantly showed better expression
performance we only had two cases two
membrane proteins where apparently based
on Western blood analysis
um the wild type construct showed a
better expression result but we believe
that this was due to a Toxic effect that
was introduced to the cells by
overexpressing the membrane protein in
the cell membrane and that this was the
reason
um for this result
okay so this slide basically shows
additional expression data where we test
it
um three intracellular proteins and now
also two antibodies which were optimized
with our Gene Optimizer algorithm for
expression in human cells as you can see
Wild type expression levels were
normalized to one and if you take a look
now at those two antibodies protein
expression yields increase by 12 to 15
times simply by optimizing the
respective heavy and light change of
those two antibodies
and finally of course we also wanted to
Benchmark our optimization approach to
other algorithms which are out in the
field and in order to this we chose a
set of kinases again Lenovo synthesized
those kinase genes as optimized and wild
type genes
head-to-head comparison on expression
level but this time we also compared
expression levels
to Wild type levels of targets that were
optimized by our combat competitors and
as you can see or what this study
revealed is that our chin Optimizer
technology was the only technology that
consistently provided higher expression
levels compared to Wild type which again
is demonstrating its high reliability
and high performance for protein
expression
um our chain Optimizer technology
provided the best results for those
kindnesses with which were tested while
no none of our competitor approaches um
showed a reliable expression performance
as they failed at least for one or the
other Gene in order to deliver better
expression results in comparison to Wild
type expression so apparently we have a
very good tool here in hand and now we
want to combine this tool with the
benefits of those at
those Advanced expression systems which
are available through Thermo Fisher
Scientific which is the XP 293 and the
expatio expression platform
so obviously protein expression plays a
role in many workflows such as
structural biology essay development or
early biologics development and
classically for years 293 cells have
frequently been used in early biologics
development due to previous difficulties
in show cells when you perform transient
expression
so which often yielded in very low
tiders of 10 to 20 milligrams per liter
only so this example workflow here now
illustrates how our XP systems are
facilitating the development of
monoclonal antibodies and vaccines
in case of monoclonal antibodies during
early development stages where groups
are still screening antibodies to select
candidates for Downstream Downstream
development researchers often use
transient systems to accelerate access
to protein and once a candidate is
selected typically a chosen line is
is made for development and
commercialization purposes however
during those development phase due to
low yields from Joe cells in the
transient mode typically the early
screening would have to be done in hack
293 cells or in a hex 2 lens free host
and then the candidate would have to be
switched again into a show cell line for
stable development which is clearly far
from being optimal
so what we see today is that those XP
systems play a major role in this early
development stages as they allow groups
now to choose between a show or a heck
host for early screening purposes and we
have seen that access to a high-yield
expression expert show system enables
groups now to start screening in
showcase and continue development in
show from Discovery to animal tries
trials which is of course a major Game
Changer over the past few years
so apparently our strategy to increase
Trends in protein years would be to
combine those highly Advanced expression
systems with our expression optimized
genes that we talked about before so we
talked
a lot about the advantages of Gene
optimization consistently providing
higher expression levels compared to
Wild type and obviously we have a very
reliable
optimization approach which is
apparently a world-class approach
meeting out our competitors
the advantages of the XP systems are
that these systems are coming basically
as a kit and it's completely
commercially available through thermal
facial scientific and this kit contains
culture medium that achieves three-fold
higher cell densities it contains cells
that are adapted to express more protein
per cell it contains transfection
reaction that effectively delivers DNA
into those High cell density cultures
and the protocol directly blocks into
our user's current 527 workflow
so
what is slide here shows now are how
high density culture media supports High
cell densities so what is shown in red
here is our xp293 cells which are
growing in xb293 media and this is
compared to excels which are growing in
a variety of other Medias and what you
can see is that the maximum densities
are much much higher meaning that early
to mid log phase growth is in a totally
different working range so the working
range up to Mid log phase allows you to
maintain those cells up to 6 million
cells per milliliter then usually you
simply passage or dilute yourself and
you are able to transfect yourself at a
density of 3 million cells per
milliliter while typically other heck
formats only allow transfection at 1
million cells per milliliter and XP show
allows to grow those cells even to
higher densities and typically an expert
show you are able to transfect yourself
at a density of 6 million cells per
milliliter and then in the end it's a
quite easy calculation you have cells
which are adapted for a higher protein
performance
protein yields the cells are growing to
a higher densities and this means you
have more cells producing protein and
this simply is supporting your high
expression yields
so
next let me jump into some of the
expression data and actually this is
data which was generated internally and
is comparing xp293 expression system to
Conventional culture systems such as the
individual chain freestyle expression
system and what we observed was a 2 to
10 volt higher protein expression
performance using the xp293 system over
those conventional
conventional hex 293 systems we even
achieved expression levels up to one
gram per liter for individual IGG
formats
and the XP expert show expression system
shows even Superior expression levels
compared to existing transient systems
so what this slide Compares are
recombinant protein titles of a human
IGG a rapid IGG and a non-antibody
format which was EPO and those were
expressed in freestyle show xp293 and
the expirito transient expression system
and as you can see the XP show system
exceeded the freestyle show system for
this human IGG by a factor of 160 and it
also exceeded those other formats by
Factor 224 when compared to the XP
provenance 3 system
this slide shows a panel of Rapid
monoclonal antibodies which were tested
in xp293 and XP show using a Max Title
protocol and this yielded in a 1.4 to
3.9 fold expression improvement over the
xp-293 system
so what you also can see is that one
monoclonal map 19 did not Express at all
in the xp293 system but it's still
delivered a decent expression level of
approximately 82 milligrams per liter in
the expirito system
we also had one candidate monoclonal 20
which did not Express in either system
and as to why this is still unclear at
this time but what it is certain is that
all of those rapid monoclonons share the
same Vector backbone with the exception
of their cdrs and so you also can see
here the significant differences so in
the impact of different ctrs for protein
expression levels
and finally this low slide shows
additional expression data comparing xp2
and xp293 and current expression system
versus the XP show system and among
again human Iggs rabbit Iggs but also
mouse icgs and a broad range of
non-antibody proteins were tested and
all showed basically lower titles than
in comparison to the expatio system so
also during this study we observed
expression level increases using the XP
show system for IGG data IGG Titus by a
factor of 0.6 to approximately a
hundredfold
thank you Dr fast
brings us to
a time-saving alternative to PCR the
gene art strings DNA fragments are
available in lengths up to 3 KB
and they are compatible with any
Downstream cloning method of choice
therefore
Gene art strings DNA fragments provides
now select all that apply
synthetic ready to use DNA fragments
DNA with your specified ends
you must have a starting DNA
free optimization of Gene Gene optimizer
option of string standing libraries
all except C
we'll give you a moment to choose your
answers
simply click on the answers that apply
for you
again that question was a time-saving
alternative to PCR the gene art strings
DNA fragments are available in lengths
up to 3 KB and are compatible with any
Downstream cloning method of choice
therefore Gene art strings DNA fragments
provides and we'd like you to select all
that apply
synthetic ready to use DNA fragments DNA
with your specified ends you must have a
DNA a starting DNA
free optimization of Gene Gene Optimizer
option of strings DNA libraries
all except for C
and C would be you must have a starting
DNA again we'll give you just another
moment to choose your answers
all right thank you everyone for
participating
with that um I would like to move on
introducing our Gene to protein service
and our service offering here at China
offers the full workflow from Gene
synthesis to protein production as a
complete workflow solution using those
Advanced XP 293 and xpit show systems so
here at qnet we strongly focus on
mammalian protein production as those
systems deliver the highest quality
proteins with the most proper function
and as most of our customers are Pharma
and biotech customers who are interested
in antibody production those are
certainly the best systems for this
purpose as they are the highest title
system on the market so we can act as an
extension of your lab
if you are using the xp293 intro system
for your research and we certainly have
the expertise with those systems so
customers who need to Outsource protein
production can be confident they get
very consistent and high performance
results
so once again I would like to point out
that our chintu protein service
completely is done in-house which
provides full control for you as a
customer but also for us as a
manufacturer which is very crucial for
many of our Pharma and biotech customers
but of course we are also closely
collaborating with the gibco and cell
bio teams of therm official scientific
and we are often serving as Alpha
customers for new for new developments
on the market
so if you order a chintu protein service
you have the full design flexibility for
your project so you can choose for
example between a hack and it show
expression system if you are interested
in a specific glycosylation pattern for
your antibody for example and of course
we are also very customized regarding
the Purity purification strategy for
your proteins
I also want to mention that Upstream of
our protein Department we have highly
specialized manufacturing departments
Who deliver high quality plasmic
preparations and of course as part of of
therm official scientific we have access
to the entire individual chain Vector
suit
but usually using those XP system our
our plasmid expression plasmate
um is the PC DNS 3.4 Vector which is
adapted um for highest performance in
those XP system
um regarding expression capabilities
also here we are very flexible with
regard to scales I will talk about this
in just one or two slides later we are
very experienced with parallel workflows
for high throughput production of
proteins so for example if you have
multiple targets to be produced and yeah
as extensively talked before now we of
course have the highest tidal systems on
the market using the XP expression
system
regarding purification we use
state-of-the-art equipment so we have
multiple active fplc devices for
parallel purifications and we all and we
have constantly growing capacity so last
year alone we produced more than 5 000
antibodies at various scales plus an
additional approximately 500 non-anti
body formats and depending on your needs
we can make things happen quite quickly
as we are part of such a big
organization which is therm official
scientific
and finally your protein also will be
analyzed of course according to your
needs and we have state of the art
analytical capabilities which can be
very basic
um basic protein biochemistry such as an
SDS shell and a western plot but of
course we also have Advanced Analytical
capabilities such as capillary gel
electrophoresis to determine purity of
your protein we can do analytical shelf
iteration via hplc to determine monomer
content of your antibody we can do
endotoxin detection and so on
so this slides yeah I I don't really
want to go into too much detail here
because it's a very busy slide but what
it Highlights Highlights is basically an
example workflow for a mammalian protein
production project basically what I only
would like to mention here is that we
offer different service types where you
can order basically protein production
from a specified culture volume or you
can order a specified amount of protein
that usually requires a pilot production
production up front in order also to
deliver full transparency for you as a
as a customer
also as you can see in this in this
slide we have several decision points
where you as a customer can decide how
to move on
um with your protein request even after
the actual production already has
started
so
into protein expression scales uh I I
mentioned it before we are very flexible
and extensible so what we offer here is
um
what we offer here is production of
protein from 30 milliliter up to three
liter in
um in Shaker flat however we also have
the capacity to produce 25 liter
production in wave bioreactors and
depending on the product mix we
currently have capacity to produce more
than 300 liter of suspension culture in
in Shaker flux per week plus an
additional 100 liter
it's 125 liter of wave bioreactor um
culture per week and what is our newest
service offering which will probably be
launched in two officially launched in
June but this is already offered to
customer is our high through Port small
scale expression format in 24 to 96
multival format and this is especially
for customers who don't need a lot of
protein for their research purposes but
yeah they need a microgram to lower
milligram range of protein for example
for initial screening purposes
with regard to expression systems we
talked about that extensively we are
focusing on the xp293 and XP show System
since those are the highest title
systems which are on the market but we
also offer sf9 insect cell production
using the bug to bugular virus
expression system and I also want to
mention that all of those reagents are
commercially available so you can
replicate your work later in-house
um
which also provides full transparency of
our processes
with regard to purification of your
protein again via a very customized
um service provider
um we produced more than 5000 protein
Productions last year
and usually
um
if it's a standard workflow usually we
start with an initial capture step using
Affinity chromatography
I mean yeah using protein HC if it's an
antibody purification but of course we
can also use a whole variety of epitope
tags for non-antibody formats
classically a histag a scrap tag but we
also use this newer nanobody
Technologies for example as ctek and we
are also very experienced in the
production of antibody formats such as
faps or Fusion proteins as well as the
production of bi-specifics
after an initial capture step we could
do intermediate purification this
usually would be Iron exchange
chromatography step and final polishing
step always is a gel filtration or a
size exclusion comma chromatography to
determine or to deliver for example an
antibody at highest quality
um again with regard to capacity
depending on the product mix in
production we are able to deliver more
than 300 antibody purifications a week
up to a certain
um culture scale
and as mentioned before we are flexible
in our capacities are constantly growing
also another slide highlighting our
analytical capabilities I also mentioned
before it could be a simple protein
biochemistry such as an SDS patch a
kubasi stand shell and the Western plot
of course always protein concentration
is delivered using nanotrop measurements
but we also have advanced capabilities
for analytics such as capillary gel
electrophoresis using a lab chip device
or we have several hplc devices for
analytical gel filtration and we do have
multiple
um
yeah possibilities to determine
endotoxin and we even can do much back
identification of an intact
anti-glycosylated antibody as a final
quality control for your protein project
thank you Dr faff
it brings us to our next poll would you
like to be contacted by technical sales
specialist team to get more assistance
on Gene Optimizer tool
yes or no
again that question is would you like to
be contacted by our technical sales
specialist team to get more assistance
on Gene Optimizer tool
yes or no
give you a moment to answer
great
thanks for your participation
so the project is completed you will
receive a full documentation of your
project so here is a document a very
basic documentation shown on this slide
which basically summarizes all the work
that was done all the material that was
used and of course it also summarizes
all the specifications of your protein
that will be delivered to you such as
yield concentration endotoxin value
monomer status whatever is requested by
you at the start of the project again
this can be highly customized to your
needs
and finally
um I would like to share some
um yeah customer examples
um some customer success stories of our
chintu protein service
so this slide basically is a case study
where a biotech company who in-house
explores novel antibody formats which
are tested on their in-house
immunotherapy platform they were using
the xp293 system for expressional
purification of those antibody targets
however they were looking for ways to
increase productivity and especially
they wanted to increase their antibody
production and they wanted to reduce the
the hours a scientists spends by
producing protein instead on focusing on
actual research work
so what we did is we introduced our
expatio expression platform to them
which immediately delivered them higher
protein years however still the
scientists in the lab spend a lot of
time by doing protein production instead
of actual research and this is when we
introduced our chintu protein service
and by Outsourcing those protein
production
um
projects this certainly helped the
customer to save time and produce
relevant antibody Targets in a very
short turnaround time so what the
customer achieved was increased
productivity with faster turnaround time
on generated data and they could
approximately 50 percent of more
proteins to be delivered simply by
Outsourcing this production of 90 of
their proteins and in some this saved
basically
more than 2 000 FTE hours a year this is
valuable time which could be spent by
the scientists in the lab on doing
actual research work
another
[Music]
um
customer example is
um work that was actually carried out by
a large Pharma customer and here
actually the protein expression part was
done in-house at the customer as he
wanted to use his in-house expression
systems however he came to us this
customer came to us with very poor
expression performance for a set of four
monoclonal antibodies basically with the
non-existing performance what we did is
we optimized the heavy chain and light
chains of those targets for expression
in a chore system we send those
constructs back to the customer he
expressed an in-house and he received a
22 to 650 volt increase in protein
production levels so basically we made
simply by optimizing those targets uh a
non-expressor to a quite decent espresso
another customer
um yeah success story here for XP 293
system and for the sake of time I'm just
focusing on the table on the lower left
here
again the customer came to us he
produced two antibodies in-house at
Titus of two milligram per liter however
this customer was still using wild type
heavy and light chain genes he was using
the endogenous leader peptide and he was
using the conventional freestyle 293
system so he outsourced the production
of those two antibodies to us we
optimized the heavy and light chains
replaced the signal peptide
and switch to the xp293 system and as
you can see we increased um
protein expression Levels by a factor of
more than a hundred so here we made a
very happy customer and again this
substantial increase in expression
levels is achieved by combining our Gene
Optimizer technology with those Advanced
expression systems which are offered
through therm official scientific and
also again I would like to stretch that
those systems are commercially available
which provides full transferability of
those processes and results for you as a
customer
so in this next slide is another story
um where we tested the XP show system so
we are first in the middle of this slide
is a nice example where you immediately
you can see how expatial outperforms
other expression systems when we express
a gfp protein however I would like to
focus on on the upper
on the upper left figure where again a
customer came to us he had a set of
antibodies that he expressed in-house
using the xp293 system he achieved
decent expression levels for a couple of
those antibodies but two antibodies
showed actually no expression he
outsourced those proteins for production
to us we switched to the XP show system
and we express those targets using the
XP show standard as well as a high
tighter protocol and as reflected by the
green bars you can you can nicely see
how protein expression levels were
increased using the XP troll system in
comparison to the xb293 expression level
which is highlighted by the blue bus and
especially I would like to draw your
attention again to those two Targets B
and D which are indicated here by those
red circles both of them were basically
non-expressor in the xb293 system but
after switching to XP show we achieved
very decent expression levels up to 100
or 200 milligrams per liter
which is of course a significant value
added and I also want to say that over
expressing those proteins in the chore
system had no negative impacts on the
quality of those antibodies as simply
reflected here
on this SDS page
um Kumasi stain shell as well as on this
hplc analysis which shows that monomer
content of this antibody was above 95
percent even without additional
polishing after putting a purification
and yeah this not only works for
Humanity cheese but it also works very
well for other antibody like formats
such as faps or by specifics and as well
for non-antibility formats especially
secreted epitope Tech non-antibody
formants
finally I also would like to show you
our newer service offering um which is a
small scale expression purification
service in 24 to 96 multival format
I mentioned it before this is intended
for customers who need initially only
small amounts of protein for example for
screening purposes but what this slide
shows is that
also here we are using the XP show
system for the expression of antibodies
that this system is highly reliable and
shows a high expression performance
constantly delivering up to 200
microgram of protein in the 96 Bill
format and up to 500 microgram in a 2012
20 well format
and yeah based on based on first
customer project we could deliver up to
500 microgram of protein for 96 well
um well production and up to 1.5 to 2
milligrams in a 24 well production
and what is shown on on the lower on the
lower left of this slide is basically
simply conditioned media loaded on an
SDS shell and you already can see the
nice performance for antibody production
in this 24 well format and on the right
on the lower right you can see how those
antibodies are will be delivered to you
as the customer as we they will be
purified using magnetic protein a
magnetic beads and this would be the
deliverable
um for the service
and this brings us to our final poll
would you like to get a quote for the
services at an early stage of your
research
select yes or no
again would you like to get a quote for
the services at the early stage of your
research
select yes or no
we'll give our audience a moment to
respond
I'd also like to make note that if you
have any questions feel free to submit
those into the ask a question box and
your answers will be responded to Via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
all right
thank you for participating
I like to stress that we offer here a
full workflow solution a highly
customized service and so we believe
it's a very smart way for you as a
customer to receive a highly expressed
and purified protein in a quite short
delivery time span and I also want to
mention that obviously along with your
protein you will also get the expression
construct delivered for further in-house
work
and I also want to mention that during
each step of your project you will be
supported by a very dedicated and
experienced project management team who
will take care of your requests and
question even after a project already
has been started
so to sum up why should you partner with
therm official scientific
um you certainly can benefit by
Outsourcing protein production projects
by at the same time getting access to
commercially available reactions so you
can replicate this work later in-house
it's a very consistent and high
performing process we are experienced in
the very or very experience in the full
workflow from synthesis to Gene
synthesis to protein production and we
are using a world-class optimization
algorithm that consistently improves
protein expression yields we have access
to the highest tidal systems on the
market which are the xp293 and XP show
Media systems and as they are produced
by thermal Fisher you will not have to
pay any additional licensing costs if
you decide to Outsource your protein
production request we are very flexible
ranging from high throughput expression
of proteins up to large-scale production
using Wi-Fi reactors
and of course you will get full
documentation and you even can get a
guaranteed amount of protein once a
pilot project is performed and with that
um if this would be of any interest for
your research this slide simply shows
how you could order tree nut protein
expression Services simply go to
thermofisher.com chintu protein or
simply contact your local sales
representatives or simply write directly
an email to gnat protein at
thermofisher.com and one of our project
management Representatives will
immediately take care of your production
request
and finally I also would like to mention
that we are at gnat in ringsbook we are
a zero waste certified manufacturing
site indeed zero percent of our waste
goes to landfill which is also something
we are very proud of
and with that I would like to finish
this presentation and yeah would be
happy to take your questions
thank you
bye
thank you Dr fath for your time today
and your informative presentation now
before we go I would like to thank our
audience for joining us and I'd also
like to thank our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for sponsoring today's
webinar
any questions submitted today and during
the on-demand period they will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration today's webcast can be
viewed on demand and labroots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and hope you enjoy the rest
of the event have a great day